بعد ساعات على مقتل مهرب مخدرات بارز
جنوبي سوريا مصادر استخباراتيه اردنيه
ودبلوماسيه غربيه كشفت ان الاردن نفذ
غارتين على موقعين المخدرات جنوبي سوريا
وفقا رويترز حيث استهدفت الغاره الاولى
معملا للكبتاجون في درعا اما الثانيه قتلت
المطلوبه الاول بتهريب المخدرات عند
الاردن مرعى الرمسان بمنزله شرقيه
السويداء والذي نقلت رويترز انه على علاقه
وثيقه بميليشيا حزب الله بدوره اوضح وزير
الخارجيه امام الصفدي انه عندما يتخذ
الاردن اي خطوه تتعلق بتهديد امنه سيعلن
عنها في الوقت المناسب مؤكدا ان بلاده
اتفقت مع سوريا على تشكيل فريق امنيا
سياسي لمواجهه خطر المخدرات
عندما نتخذ اي خطوه
لحمايه امننا الوطني ومواجهتي اي تهديد له
سنعلنها في وقتها المناسب بالنسبه لقضيه
المخدرات كما اكدنا سابقا هو هي تهديد
كبير للمملكه وللمنطقه وللعالم ايضا في
ضوء تصاعد عمليات تهريب المخدرات تذكرين
اننا في اجتماع عمان اشرنا الى هذا
اتفقنا مع اخوتنا في الحكومه السوريه
باننا سنشكل فريقا سياسيا
امنيا مشتركا لمواجهه هذا الخطر
الانتهاء منه بشكل كامل مستمرون في العمل
من اجل انشاء تلك اللجنه وساتصل بمعالي
وزير الخارجيه السوريه قريبا لنبحث كيف
نترجم هذا الاتفاق الى اليه عمل واضحه
تساعدنا على مواجهه هذا الخطر وتحدوا منه
وعلى اتصال وقنواتنا مفتوحه مع الحكومه
السوريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات